qué consecuencias para la salud pueden
traer realmente estas manifestaciones en
las que incluso pues muchas personas
acuden acuden sin medidas de protección
con estas manifestaciones son
verdaderamente absurdas y sumamente
negativas para el control de la pandemia
recordemos que en buena parte de europa
estamos ante repuntes considerables que
constituyen ya la cuarta ola de la
pandemia es el caso de españa- pero es
el caso de muchos otros países europeos
la situación francesa es extrema de más
de 700 casos por 100.000 habitantes
italia tiene más de 500 casos por
100.000 habitantes
holanda en los países bajos y bélgica
tienen una incidencia de más de 450 y la
propia alemania de más de 250 españa por
fortuna está en una incidencia media de
150 menor que estos otros países pero
con algunas comunidades autónomas como
madrid el país vasco o navarra ceuta
melilla con incidencias de más de 250
pensar que es absurdo tener
restricciones como se manifiesta en
estas personas que además lo hacen sin
mascarillas sin protección
de la mente negacionista y por otro lado
profundamente dañino para el tema del
control de la transmisión no se están
respetando las las medidas restrictivas
que tienen que ponerse en marcha para
poder frenar una incidencia tan alta
como la que estamos doctores y en medio
de este creciente número de contagios de
esta incidencia de la que usted nos
habla que atraviesa europa en esta
tercera y hasta cuarta ola y con
vacunación estancada usted cree que los
confinamientos a estas alturas si son
efectivos
bueno en situaciones como la que se ha
llegado en francia o en o en italia no
hay duda de que hay que llegar a medidas
más extremas que implican un
confinamiento en confinamiento severo
como desde el principio la pandemia o un
confinamiento online no basta con las
medidas de un 'toque de queda' es suave
con restricciones de la actividad en
horarios nocturnos no basta con los
confinamientos perimetrales como los que
se hacen en españa para que no se las
personas no viajen en una comunidad
autónoma a otra hay que instrumentar
medidas severas de restricción de
actividades gregarias en espacios
interiores en mal ventilados en
gimnasios en bares en locales de
restauración en donde no se garantiza
una ventilación adecuada recordemos que
lo único que nos va a permitir frenar en
estos momentos la expansión de la
pandemia son
los límites a la movilidad y los límites
que establezcan las restricciones para
poder tener una acción libre de contagio
la vacunación todavía no nos alcanza
para frenar estas zonas tenemos que
seguir avanzando a toda velocidad pero
todavía nos faltan meses para lograr los
niveles de vacunación que nos permitan
realmente detener este avance y doctor
muy brevemente todos esos problemas que
tenemos ahora con repuntes es porque la
gente está dejando de creer en la
evidencia médica
yo creo que ese es un factor que está
contribuyendo ahí hay un conjunto de
factores la fatiga pandémica el hecho de
que la gente resiste menos las medidas
restrictivas el el descreimiento con
respecto a las medidas a la evidencia
científica y la confusión que genera una
información no sustentada en bases
científicas yo creo que tenemos que
entender que estamos en un momento en
donde todavía hay que hacer sacrificios
mientras podemos vacunar a más personas